it's Thursday August eighteenth I'm Mary
and you're watching gamespot news first
up Microsoft is saying that they're
skinny Xbox one s is off to a really
speedy start demand has been off the
charts for Microsoft's newly launched
Xbox one s console Xbox marketing
executive aaron greenberg said that
Microsoft is seen unprecedented demand
for the slim down system now we haven't
seen any specific sales numbers but the
system's two terabyte version is sold
out in many stores in Europe but luckily
if you are looking for an xbox one s
more coming soon on august twenty-third
there's gonna be three new versions
offered a one terabyte model that comes
with madden NFL 17 for 350 bucks and a
500 gigabyte version that's 300 bucks
and a one terabyte version that comes
with halo 5 guardians and halo the
master chief collection that's 350 bucks
the Xbox one makes using an external
hard drive easy so compensating for the
smaller hard drive sizes is painless and
relatively inexpensive the Xbox one s
debuted earlier this month introducing
4k and HDR support in a smaller sleeker
better-looking box it also provides a
performance boost in some but not all
games we have a full review on the slim
and you can check it out on games file
next up I got more Microsoft news
because there's new information on
project Scorpio aaron greenberg is at it
again with new insight into the
company's upcoming project scorpio
system which they're calling the most
powerful console ever made greenberg was
asked by engadget if this is the final
console generation and he said i think
it is that's because he said project
scorpio doesn't constitute a new
generation per se because it's backwards
compatible he went on to talk about the
response by the public so far based on
the reaction there appears to be a lot
of demand and interest around project
scorpio and we think it's going to be a
pretty big success he also discussed
backwards compatibility saying if you
bought games and accessories for xbox
one or you buy an xbox one s those games
and accessories are going to work on
project Scorpio when you think about
backwards compatibility in our games
lineup we want gamers to know that when
they're ready to upgrade to Scorpio that
content will go with them that's our
promise and commitment around
compatibility that's pretty good news
there's more than 230 games in the xbox
one's backwards compatibility lineup and
red dead redemption is finally among
them the last piece of Scorpio news they
won't have any exclusive games except
for virtual reality titles project
Scorpio or whatever Microsoft will end
up calling it is slated to arrive in
holiday 2017 you might not be able to
play a deus ex mankind divided yet which
can are in skill points for it by
playing Deus Ex go completing certain
tasks in the mobile game earns you
praxis kits that you can use in the xbox
one and pc versions of mankind divided
praxis kits are consumable items that
can grant the player a skill point that
can be assigned to the augmentation tree
Deus Ex go has five of these available
for players to obtain completing the
story mode gets you two while clearing
any level with mastermind status
finishing each puzzle in a certain
number of moves earns you another the
other two are obtained by completing
your first and second sets of weekly
puzzles to claim these practice kits as
your own you're gonna have to sign up or
login with your square UNIX ID once
mankind divided releases you can sign in
with your square enix ID on the xbox one
or PC and your practice kits will unlock
for use in game now unfortunately these
bonuses aren't redeemable yet on ps4
we've contacted Square Enix and asked
them why you can't do that or if you'll
ever get the chance to redeem those
practice kits but you'll have to go to
gamespot for that reply when we get one
so that technically all the news I have
for you today but they can't stop me
from telling you that the overwatch
animated short film bastion came out
today and it's so good so you have to go
watch it and I'll see you guys again
tomorrow
you